je vais vous faire une révélation si
wanda est strange peuvent interagir dans
un autre univers dans Doctor Strange 2
c'est parce que le Dark old agit en fait
comme un VPN malheureusement je ne peux
pas vous offrir le darkoald pour des
raisons évidentes néanmoins j'ai quelque
chose qui pourrait vous intéresser vous
l'aurez compris cette vidéo est
sponsorisée par North VPN grâce à Nantes
VPN en un seul clic et ce depuis
n'importe où vous pouvez changer votre
localisation pour accéder au contenu de
n'importe quel endroit vous voulez
revoir Black Panther Wakanda Forever
c'est possible vous êtes intéressé par
le catalogue d'un autre pays pas de
problème accéder à tout le contenu que
vous souhaitez partout dans le monde en
restant chez vous sans oublier que
norvpn est d'ailleurs un outil très
sécurisé qui vous protège contre les
criminels et la surveillance sur le web
à noter également que grâce à ses 5200
serveurs répartis dans plus de 60 pays
Nantes VPN est très rapide d'exécution
et en plus accessible via six appareils
différents donc de quoi en faire
profiter l'entourage alors si vous
voulez maîtriser votre activité et
accéder au réseau Internet mondial sans
utiliser le Dark allld ou les rêves
passerelles et enclenché du coup une
incursion profiter de l'offre North BPN
s'est allant sur deux ans dont un mois
gratuit et une grande réduction tout ça
satisfait ou remboursé sur 30 jours le
lien est disponible dans la description
merci à nortvpn que la vidéo commence
à la fin de la vidéo centrée sur Doctor
Strange 3 et les dimensions je vous
avais parlé que je voulais développer
une théorie autour de Wanda concernant
The Kang dynastie et Secret Wars à la
toute base je pensais l'intégrer à la
vidéo que j'aimerais vous faire pour les
100000 abonnés car je pense et vous
serez d'accord avec moi Wanda sera très
important pour la saga du multivers mais
voilà il y a beaucoup de choses à dire
donc je me dis qu'une vidéo dédiée à
Wanda ne ferait pas de mal et
permettrait pourquoi pas d'éclaircir la
situation néanmoins j'aimerais vous
avertir à l'heure actuelle au moment où
on se parle nous n'avons aucune
information concernant la Scarlet witch
dans le MCU on se doute très fortement
qu'elle sera dans les prochains films
Avengers au minimum ainsi que très
certainement la série d'Agata arknes
mais ça s'arrête là dans cette vidéo je
vais donc vous partager purement et
simplement ma vision et mes idées
admettons que je travaille chez Marvel
studio je vais vous proposer ce que moi
je ferai pour le développement du
personnage de Wanda dans l'avenir du MCU
donc sur ce si vous êtes prêt ne tarde
pas plus longtemps on y va
[Musique]
voilà
est très populaire nous avons beaucoup
parlé d'elle sur la chaîne on connaît
très très bien son histoire depuis
Avengers se l'ère d'ultron néanmoins
cette fois-ci pour que nous puissions
aller plus loin il faut que nous
parlions de l'essence même du personnage
de Wanda ce qui la caractérise vraiment
dans les comics et vous allez voir que
cela a clairement son importance wanda
est une héroïne singulière dans
l'univers Marvel et a juste titre elle
est ce qu'on appelle un Nexus Bing et
plus particulièrement le Nexus Bing de
l'univers 616 soit l'univers principal
que nous suivons dans les comics alors
les Nexus Bing pour celles et ceux qui
ne savent pas ce sont des êtres Nexus
lenexus ça par contre vous savez ce que
c'est de par la série Loki c'est le
moment où un élément du temps a été
modifié et qui va avoir pour conséquence
de créer une autre ligne temporelle
différente car quelque chose choses qui
n'aurait pas dû être touchée l'a été et
bien les êtres Nexus reprennent
exactement ce procédé ce sont des
personnes qui sont tellement importantes
tellement puissantes et ou ancrées dans
l'histoire qu'ils peuvent à eux seuls
influencer le futur de l'univers et sa
direction ce sont des gens qui en gros
affectent les probabilités car à la base
le futur reste quelque chose d'un
certain donc si un être Nexus intervient
et bien ses actions ont de très très
grandes chances de modifier l'avenir et
par conséquent de créer de nouvelles
lignes temporelles de plus dans les
règles du multivers apportés par les
comics il existerait apparemment un être
Nexus par réalité quand le Conquérant
par exemple qui est issu de la réalité
6311 c'est l'être Nexus de ce monde
Wanda du coup ces lettres Nexus de la
réalité 616 mais en soi n'importe qui
peut l'être fun fact il y a une réalité
la 900 ou Napoléon Bonaparte et lettre
Nexus et pourquoi cela et bien tout
simplement car là-bas il a conquis la
Russie bref je pense que vous avez
compris ce qui était un Nexus Bing mais
pourquoi on parle de ça du coup et bien
tout d'abord pour souligner le caractère
unique de Wanda la Sorcière Rouge
possède un pouvoir inégalé elle est
l'héroïne la plus puissante la magie du
Chaos est une sorcellerie que seul
ouanda a en sa possession carcton
lui-même le créateur de cette magie un
des dieux anciens a choisi la jeune
femme comme réceptacle la magie du chaos
et si singulière qu'elle permet à son
utilisateur de déformer le tissu de
l'existence à sa guise et en fonction de
ses humeurs dans Wanda vision Wanda
alors qu'elle n'est pas encore devenue
la Scarlet witch à générer un Nexus
temporaire via la magie du ex où elle a
réécrit l'existence en fonction de ses
caprices fan de sitcom et désireuse de
retrouver trouver le bonheur et fonder
sa famille ouest View est devenu une
pseudo-réalité où tout est remanié en
émission télévisée accompagné de vision
à qui elle a redonné naissance ainsi que
de ses deux enfants Billy et Tommy c'est
déjà fou ce qu'elle a accompli dans
Wanda vision mais tout ça c'était un
avant-goût un teasing pour montrer au
téléspectateurs ce que Wanda est capable
de faire et c'est là que les choses
intéressantes se profile si wanda est si
puissante si elle est capable de
réécrire la réalité et influencer le
futur est-ce que cela n'éveillerait pas
du coup les convoitises de certains
l'une des grandes caractéristiques du
personnage de Wanda maximum dans les
comics c'est que bien qu'elle soit
immensément puissante en termes de
pouvoir et bien de l'autre côté en tant
qu'humaine elle est plutôt fragile
néanmoins c'est tout à fait normal
qu'elle le soit alors que Wanda pourrait
écraser n'importe qui en duel elle se
fait toujours malmener dans sa vie il
n'y a pas un seul autre personnage qui
souffre autant que Wanda durant toute
son existence elle va enchaîner les
malheurs son cœur sera meurtri à de
multiples reprises et ses désirs même
les plus simples se termineront à chaque
fois sur un lourd tourment
wanda est dans une détresse la plus
totale sa vie n'est qu'une désolation
mais vous êtes-vous déjà demandé
pourquoi le personnage souffre autant et
bien il est clair que déjà il y a un
objectif narratif ou le but est de
descendre le personnage pour mieux le
remonter et mieux le construire derrière
mais pas seulement en fait vu que Wanda
est détentrice de la magie du chaos et
symbolise l'être Nexus de la terre 606
et bien parmi les nombreux vilains qui
ont voulu manipuler Wanda pour son
pouvoir un seul la manipule en réalité
depuis de nombreuses années
dernière identité de Kang le Conquérant
Immortus et la forme la plus sage et
unique de ces variants c'est simple il
est le seul dans le multivers à être
Immortus c'est variant n'ont jamais
atteint et n'atteindront jamais cette
identité en tant que seigneur des limbes
Immortus a été approché par les Times
Keepers eux-mêmes pour qu'ils deviennent
leur modérateur du temps le rôle des
trois êtres est simple surveillez que le
multivers aille dans le bon sens et
suivent le bon cours du temps pour qu'à
terme à la fin des temps ces derniers
existent pour l'univers suivant il faut
voir ça comme un gigantesque puzzle les
thèmes Keepers font face à un casse-tête
continuel où ils influencent les
réalités pour que l'histoire se déroule
d'une manière très précise pour le bon
fonctionnement du flux temporel Immortus
étant invariant unique de kangle
conquérant qui a dépassé ses autres
lui-même a donc pour rôle imposé par les
timekeepers de démêler les conflits
corporelle créée par celui du passé
quand le conquérant et ses variants et
plus globalement gérer la période de
3000 avant JC jusqu'à l'an 4000 et tout
ça c'est quelque chose d'hyper important
à avoir en tête car durant toute
l'histoire vécue par nos super-héros et
bien en fait il y a énormément de
moments impactés par les actions
d'immortus afin que les héros et je
dirais même l'histoire en général soit
guidée et prenne une direction souhaitée
par les thèmes Keepers et vous vous en
doutez mais c'est également le cas de
Wanda en fait pour être plus précis en
plus de la condition unique de Wanda il
y a une légende qui circule le
concernant les êtres Nexus et qui
intéresse et à la fois inquiète les
êtres supérieurs comme les thèmes
Keepers c'est la descendance de ces
êtres d'exception un être Nexus est déjà
si impactant dans son univers que sa
descendance pourrait l'être encore plus
et se hisser parmi les plus grands êtres
Kang par exemple c'est déjà énormément
intéressé à ce concept et c'est même
devenu quelque chose de principal dans
son histoire après l'événement de la
guerre du destin déjà le coût de
l'amadon Céleste la fameuse femme qui
est censée donner naissance à un être
d'exception Kang voulait trouver cette
protagoniste et en faire sa femme pour
donner naissance à un héritier encore
plus fort que lui qu'il pourrait
manipuler il suspectait Wanda d'être la
Madone céleste mais ce fut finalement
Mantis the gang dynastie c'est pareil
Kang étant lettre Nexus de sa réalité il
va chercher à s'accoupler avec
d'innombrables femmes avec une génétique
dite exceptionnelle pour donner
naissance à un fils parfait ce qui va
résulter du coup l'existence de Marcus
le 23e fils et c'est du vilain qui
l'estimera au final être un nouvel échec
pour revenir à Wanda je pense que vous
voyez où je veux en venir le fait que
cette dernière donne naissance à des
enfants et quelque chose qui d'A les
thèmes Keepers pourrait chambouler le
cosmos et du coup Immortus va agir en
conséquence mais il va faire même pire
que ça alors que les thèmes Keepers sont
plus dans une optique de on supprime ce
qui nous dérange on remodule eux ils
sont clairement dans une partie d'échec
un puzzle à résoudre et bien Immortus
lui ne veut pas tuer au contraire au
premier abord on pourrait se dire que
c'est sympa de sa part mais au final il
va plus souvent aggraver la situation
faire souffrir et des fois son naturel
lui-même va reprendre le dessus il va
agir pour lui et en son nom dans le
cadeau Wanda Immortus va souhaiter en
réalité en faire une
ultimate Nexus c'est à dire un être
Nexus mais qui ne s'arrête pas qu'à son
univers on parle ici d'un être Nexus
mais pour le multivers en entier soit
quelqu'un qui est capable de manipuler
le multivers lui-même et pour ce faire
il va jouer entre guillemets avec la vie
de Wanda toutes les atrocités que la
protagon a vécu c'est pour qu'à terme
Wanda soit isolé souffrante et en colère
et cela permettra à cette dernière de
libérer son pouvoir ainsi que vu qu'elle
est seule se rapprocher d'immortus qui
dans un élan de manipulation la
prendrait sous son aile en quelque sorte
si vision a vu le jour c'est parce qu'il
meurtus a agi pour qu'il existe ensuite
c'est lui qui l'a guidé vers les
Avengers qui la rapproché de Wanda et
qui les ont fait tomber amoureux et pour
tout vous dire Immortus a même marié les
deux personnages
et accessoirement vu que vision est un
synthésoïde c'était un moyen pour que
Wanda à terme n'est pas d'enfant je ne
vous fait pas un dessin sauf que le truc
vous le savez tout comme dans Wanda
vision Wanda va donner naissance à Billy
et Tommy grâce à sa magie du chaos mais
étant donné que l'énergie qui a permis
de donner naissance aux enfants étaient
liés à Mephisto Immortus a comploté avec
ce dernier pour que lui et son soldat
pandémonium récupère l'âme de Billy et
Tommy une perte qui va détruire
psychologiquement Wanda et qui va
énormément affecter son couple à terme
pour encore et toujours plus isoler la
sorcière immorteuse va interagir pour
éloigner vision dans le but qu'il soit
démembré et réassembler ce qui va avoir
pour résultat de donner naissance au
White vision c'est à dire le même
personnage avec tous ses souvenirs mais
sans les sentiments et les émotions qui
vont avec encore un énorme coup dur pour
Rwanda bon au final bien évidemment le
plan d'immortus dans les comics échoura
mais Wanda en aura pris plein la figure
pendant des années juste pour ça bref
depuis le début je vous instaure des
concepts je vous explique un petit peu
les comics etc mais ce qui ne serait pas
temps d'adapter tout ça pour le MCU il
est temps que je vous partage ma vision
complète concernant Wanda
bien évidemment vous l'aurez remarqué
par le biais des comics mais plusieurs
éléments ont déjà été mis en place dans
le MCU par rapport à tout ça Wanda et
Avengers qui a pris le plus cher depuis
le début la vie ne lui a fait aucun
cadeau et elle s'est toujours retrouvée
isolée et quand finalement l'espoir
revient grâce à la présence de vision et
la naissance de leur histoire d'amour
tout par encore une fois en vrille au
point que Wanda va craquer et réveiller
son véritable pouvoir qui lui permettra
de ramener un vision de substitution
ainsi que ses enfants mais
malheureusement cela ne pouvait pas
durer et ouest view fut un fiasco
complet mais la souffrance de Wanda lui
a ouvert les yeux sur sa condition et en
possession du Dark old l'ouvrage
normalement écrit par tonne lui-même
cette dernière a énormément évolué sur
le plan de la sorcellerie néanmoins une
fois encore la jeune femme sera
manipulée et le Dark hold lui causera
énormément de souffrance au point
qu'elle va s'autodétruire et c'est ça le
truc important à retenir ici Wanda
souffre et cela lui permet d'É et
d'ouvrir les yeux sur ses pouvoirs car
en fait elle est tout le temps poussée à
bout malgré elle Wanda pète tout
simplement les plombs à cause de ce
qu'elle endure au quotidien et quand on
apprend que derrière tout l'univers
Marvel un variant de Kang a tracé et
connaît toute l'histoire avec pour but
de revenir sur son trône à la fin et
bien on peut s'interroger sur le fait
que par rapport au comics ils vont ici
dans le MCU reproduire similairement ce
schéma on fait souffrir Wanda elle
évolue et ses pouvoirs vont permettre
d'amener quelque chose qui va influencer
la future guerre multiverselle mais bon
je vous parle de tout ça sauf qu'on en
est quand même encore bien loin essayons
plutôt de tracer la route de Wanda telle
celui qui demeure jusqu'aux événements
de the Kong dynastie et Secret Wars pour
expliquer tout d'abord le retour de
Wanda il faut se pencher sur le sujet
des dimensions effectivement on a bien
exploré le sujet dans la vidéo dédiée à
Dr Strange 3 mais en gros l'univers
Marvel des jonchés de royaume de toutes
sortes le royaume quantique Asgard Talo
le void pour ne citer que mais cela ne
s'arrête pas là vous voyez l'ancestral
plane de Black Panther ou celui de
Moonlight ou bien encore tout simplement
le val Hala dans Thor 4 ces endroits
sont des sortes de paradis des royaumes
d'après vie où les morts se retrouvent
et bien en réalité ce sont des
dimensions ce n'est pas par hasard si
moonight arrive en sortir si les Black
Panther en reviennent une fois
l'herbe-cœur ingéré ou si comme dans les
comics Odin ou d'autres Asgardiens
interviennent dans la réalité les
dimensions je vous le rappelle mais
c'est simplement un morceau de réalité
contenant de l'espace et du temps et qui
est influencé par son emplacement
spatial du coup il y a moyen d'y accéder
mais aussi d'en revenir pour moi Wanda
avec son auto-destruction a atterri dans
l'un de ses royaumes mais pas n'importe
lequel lors de son combat avec America
Chavez la Scarlet twitch s'est trouver
un court moment en difficulté America
est en capable d'ouvrir des portails
vers d'autres mondes que ce soit des
univers alternatifs ou des royaumes nous
a amenés dans un endroit très
intéressant un véritable monde de
flammes jonchée de rocher magmatiques et
de lave en fusion
inutile de vous faire un dessin je
soupçonne très fortement que nous soyons
face au royaume des enfers alors c'est à
ce moment là où vous allez me dire ok
pourquoi pas mais ça me semble pas mal
tiré par les cheveux vous vous doutez
bien que si j'en parle c'est pour une
raison très particulière les enfers mais
attention pas les véritables sont régnés
par le célèbre antagoniste Méphisto et
sincèrement pour moi il n'y a pas
meilleure manière pour introduire le
personnage que d'utiliser Wanda à
l'heure actuelle dans le MCU Wanda a
tout simplement pris conscience de son
pouvoir et à péter les plombs à cause du
Dark old mais cela s'arrête là elle n'a
pas encore fait la découverte du retour
de vision en white vision ce qui va lui
mettre un sacré coup mais surtout elle
n'a pas encore véritablement résolu le
cas de ses enfants de la même manière
que cela a été fait dans les comics
Wanda a donné naissance à Tommy et Billy
grâce à sa magie sauf que ces derniers
ne sont pas réels et strange a bien su
lui rappeler
Tommy et Billy ne peuvent pas vivre dans
la réalité 616 ils ont besoin du ex pour
ça néanmoins c'est un peu particulier
mais de l'autre côté cela ne veut pas
dire qu'il n'existe pas non plus il
reste de véritables êtres vivants ce qui
veut dire en gros que ces derniers ont
une âme mais ne peuvent pas prospérer
dans la réalité du coup bah qu'est-ce
qu'il se passe et bien pour moi Méphisto
va vouloir tout simplement récupérer
l'âme des enfants surtout si en plus on
suit la légende comme quoi la
descendance des Nexus being serait des
êtres d'exception et cela ferait du coup
écho à ce qui s'est passé dans les
comics c'est pour moi le le meilleur
moyen de clôturer cette thématique des
enfants et même plus que ça encore vous
le savez très certainement mais Tommy et
Billy font partie des Young Avengers
dans les comics ils vont atteindre l'âge
adulte et devenir des super-héros mais
comment tout ça c'est possible et bien
c'est un peu confus dans les comics mais
en gros Tommy et Billy après avoir
disparu à cause de mes fistaux vont se
réincarner grâce au pouvoir de Wanda il
naîtront dans une autre famille
cependant il garderont un lien très
proche avec leur mère spirituel qu'il
rechercheront pendant de nombreuses
années pour avoir la confirmation et
Wanda qui n'était pas au courant les
reconnaîtra finalement pour le MCU je me
dis qu'il y a moyen de réunir tous ces
éléments et les adapter pour tracer
l'avenir Wanda avec son auto-destruction
finirait dans les enfers de Mephisto qui
tenterait de récupérer l'âme de la
sorcière la plus puissante du monde
là-bas elle se rendrait compte que
finalement même si ses enfants
n'existent pas leur âme sont quant à
elle bien et du coup il y a moyen de les
libérer pour permettre peut-être pas une
réincarnation comme dans les comics mais
un véritable retour des enfants qui
pourraient cette fois-ci enfin vivre
dans l'univers 616 pleinement néanmoins
par rapport à tout ça il y a un
personnage clé dont nous n'avons pas
encore parlé c'est Agathe Agatha a bien
que secondaire aura son rôle à jouer ce
n'est pas par hasard si cette dernière
aura sa propre série sur Disney plus la
particularité dont nous avons fait face
dans le MCU c'est kagata était une
antagoniste chose qui n'est pas du tout
le cas dans les comics pour être tout à
fait honnête la sorcière sera même la
mentor de Wanda et elle va l'épauler à
de multiples reprises c'est son allié la
plus fidèle par exemple pour le cas de
Mephisto Agatha sera celle qui va
soulager la perte de Rwanda en lui
jetant un sortilège affectant sa mémoire
pour le cas d'immortus c'est agatha qui
va finalement faire révéler le plan du
maître du temps aux Avengers et qui va
permettre à Wanda d'échapper au destin
que lui avait prévu l'antagoniste et le
truc c'est que savoir kagata aura sa
propre série pose question parce qu'en
réalité je ne vais pas vous mentir la
sorcière sert avant tout de camarades et
de piliers pour Rwanda et accessoirement
agrémenter le l'or autour des sorcières
de Salem ainsi que leur héritage mais
c'est tout Agatha n'a pas d'autre
utilité scénaristique du coup pour le
MCU je me dis que la série est un piège
Marvel ne peut nous proposer un
programme orienté à 100% sur le passé et
le Lore des sorcières il faut que
l'histoire est l'univers avancent
également pour moi Agatha coven of Kaos
ce sera une série qui va effectivement
agrémenter le Lore des sorcières qui est
actuellement absent dans le MCU mais qui
va permettre également le retour de
Wanda
subtilement le MCU nous attisé que
malgré leur confrontation Agatha est
quelqu'un qui a guidé tout le long de la
série et qui lui a enseigné au final la
bonne manière pour qu'elle battent une
autre sorcière nous allons faire face à
une sorte de rédemption Agatha ne peut
laisser Wanda vagabonder librement
sachant qu'elle n'a aucune formation de
sorcière qu'elle est en possession de la
magie du chaos synonyme de prophétie
apocalyptique et qu'en plus elle lui a
volé le Dark old Wanda ayant désormais
parfaitement épouser sa forme de Scarlet
witch Agatha ne peut plus rien faire
contre elle elle n'est plus en capacité
de lui voler ses pouvoirs donc si Marvel
a décidé de ramener la protagoniste pour
développer sa propre série c'est pour
qu'à terme elle se rapproche de ce
qu'elle est dans les comics une mentor
pour Wanda celle qui va lui enseigner et
l'aider à maîtriser ses pouvoirs au
point même de former un duo tout ceci
permettra à notre héroïne de se
reconstruire prendre conscience de ses
pouvoirs et de son importance dans le
multivers et à terme nous pourrons faire
face à The candynastie et Secret Wars
Rwanda devrait normalement atteindre son
pic de grandeur
[Musique]
la série Loki nous a dévoilé l'existence
du flux temporel sacré un flux temporel
que nous suivons depuis le tout premier
film du MCU et ce dernier a été isolé
par celui qui demeure qui est le seul
survivant et le grand gagnant de la
guerre multiverselle c'est donc par
logique la révélation que l'univers 616
est principale tout comme ça l'est dans
les comics mais pour des raisons de
facilité de lecture et de scénario sauf
que si l'on prend en compte l'existence
des êtres Nexus et bien cela veut dire
que Wanda est incroyablement importante
pour celui qui demeure et par conséquent
c'est l'adaptation pure et simple de ce
qui nous a été proposé dans les comics
depuis le début la vie de Wanda a été
tracée par celui qui demeure tout
simplement car ce dernier reproduit le
travail des thèmes keep des comics le
flux temporel doit se dérouler d'une
manière bien précise pour qu'au moment
de son reset tout doit être prêt tout
doit être aligné pour que celui qui
demeure retrouve son titre et sa place
de grands vainqueurs en tant qu'être
Nexus capable d'influencer les
probabilités futures celui qui demeure a
donc façonné l'histoire pour que Wanda
emprunte une route très précise une
route où elle va énormément souffrir à
connaître énormément de pertes mais qui
à la fin va éveiller tout son potentiel
un potentiel qui a été taquiné dans Dr
Strange in the Multiverse of Mendes
puisque là où Immortus a échoué dans les
comics pour que Wanda devienne un
ultimate Nexus dans le MCU Wanda a
atteint ce pic la sorcière a détruit le
Dark old et ce dans tous les univers
comme ça personne ne sera tenté sauf que
de l'autre côté cela annonce quelque
chose de plus grand Rwanda par le biais
de cette action de nous prouver qu'elle
était capable d'influencer le futur des
autres réalités puisqu'en détruisant le
darkhould cela signifie que celles et
ceux qui devaient les utiliser dans
leurs univers respectifs ne l'ont pas
fait et ne le pourront jamais Wanda
vient d'influencer les probabilités des
autres univers en supprimant la
possibilité que le Dark old influence
l'histoire de certains personnages
exemple simple notre Wanda dans
l'univers 616 a pu devenir immensément
puissante car elle a étudié le Dark old
pendant un long moment mais du coup en
le détruisant la majorité des Rwanda des
autres univers ne pourront pas avoir
accès à ce dernier les empêchant donc de
pleinement épouser leur forme de Scarlet
witch elle resteront donc à jamais des
sorcières rouges bas de gamme ce qui
d'ailleurs propulse de l'autre côté
notre Rwanda comme entité majeur du
multivers puisque elle sera complètement
supérieure
les autres elle-même et du coup qui va
bénéficier de tout ça pendant la guerre
multiverselle traduit dans le MCU en
tant que film Avengers Secret Wars et
bien c'est le Nathaniel Richards destiné
à devenir celui qui demeure face aux
incursions face aux autres camps et face
aux autres Wanda notre Scarlet twitch
aura la capacité de les anni les et les
surpasser pour permettre à la terre 616
de se propulser en tant que flûte
temporel principal et par ailleurs la
condition de Nexus
ultime du multivers que symbolise wanda
est également traduit par le biais de
ses actions dans Dr Strange 2 malgré ses
rêves passerelles malgré l'assassinat
des illuminatis Wanda n'aura finalement
causé aucune incursion tout comme
America Chavez capable de voyager dans
le multivers sans provoquer le moindre
souci c'est à chaque fois Doctor Strange
qui sera responsable des problèmes car
lui par contre n'est pas un être Nexus
par conséquent c'est aussi la révélation
que Wanda aurait la
des univers de l'intérieur sans laisser
de trace et ce bien avant l'avènement
des incursions une aubaine pour celui
qui demeure qui a tout programmé et tout
orienté néanmoins il est clair que la
Scarlet twitch finira à terme par
trouver sa rédemption elle qui est
devenue une antagoniste dans Doctor
Strange 2 retrouvera la raison quand le
plan du maître du temps sera en famille
à jour lui prouvant qu'elle est
désormais maîtresse de son destin et
qu'elle est enfin libre de trouver la
sérénité et le bonheur
J'espère de tout cœur que la vidéo vous
aura plu n'hésitez pas à me le faire
savoir avec un beau pouce bleu un
commentaire et en vous abonnant à la
chaîne bien évidemment n'empêche je me
rends compte mais depuis le début je
n'arrête pas de dire que Wanda est
unique c'est bizarre un peu non est-ce
que ça serait pas annonciateur de
quelque chose bon écoutez je préfère
m'arrêter là on se retrouve très vite
dans une prochaine vidéo c'était hargo
rock que le lion Hart soit avec vous
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]